Donald Trump is set to terminate the
press rights of the New York Times in
the Washington Post these are two of the
most important investigative media
outlets in the Trump era and because
Donald Trump doesn't like them he is now
saying he will be terminating their
White House press credentials now one of
the things that has it was going to be a
focus actually of my keynote address at
the grassroots radio conference in
Rochester New York a couple of weeks ago
unfortunately that event had to be
cancelled because I ended up in the
hospital with an emergency appendectomy
and I was not able to give this talk but
I was going to focus on the strength of
the attacks on media under the current
administration we've seen this concerted
authoritarian disdain towards the media
everything from threatening libel
lawsuits to proposing journalism
licenses to talking about shutting down
media outlets and should certain media
outlets even be allowed to exist which
is a very authoritarian concept even
rising to the level of going after
targeting attacking individual
journalists some of whom have actually
as a result of being targeted by Donald
Trump in the administration been the
targets of physical violence at events
and Trump rallies and now Donald Trump
in a total Gong Show interview that ran
an hour with his buddy Sean Hannity on
Fox News last night is saying that his
administration will be terminating the
press credentials of the New York Times
and The Washington Post let's take a
look at it Sean Hannity of course just
gushing and thrilled he'll it might even
have been Sean Hannity's idea that
Donald Trump do this we know that
Hannity frequently talks to Donald Trump
before Trump goes to bed extraordinarily
romantic isn't it let's take a look
option that something has to be
investigated that's what you have to
look but I watch this crazy Anderson
Cooper the other day during the debate
apologize for having to ask the question
to them apologist if that were me he
declared her innocence if that were my
son's that took 168 thousand dollars
from this very questionable company an
energy company and they knew nothing
about energy you know he knew nothing
about energy
and he has a bad record bad track record
including getting thrown out of the Navy
and even the way he got in the Navy is
interesting in his position if that were
Don Jr if that were Eric Trump were very
outstanding young men it would be the
biggest story of the century what does
it say about the media I agree with you
the media is corrupt
not all media's look I know some some
great people including you but I know
some great journalists look I think a
Pulitzer Prizes to people they got it
wrong okay all these people Fortuna from
the New York Times which is a fake
newspaper we don't even want it in the
White House anymore gonna probably
terminate that in the Washington Post if
fake but you take a look at the New York
Times and you take a look at the kind of
reporting they do it was all it turned
out to be all wrong now you can probably
guess that everything Trump said there
is a lie but I want to focus in
specifically on the media attacks you
know he talks about crazy Anderson
Cooper again another example of
targeting specific journalists he throws
hunter Biden under the bus I thought
that the children of elected officials
were off-limits but then it's the big
media attack the corrupt media we need
to terminate the New York Times and The
Washington Post now I don't believe that
he is saying he needs to terminate them
as entities although he's alluded to
shutting down media outlets in the past
it's pretty clear that what he means is
terminating their access to White House
press briefings which by the way there
hasn't been one for nine months and you
know traveling with the president and
this type of thing this is how tyranny
slowly starts to rain this is how
authoritarianism develops and the
pro-gun people always talk about we need
our handguns and rifles to protect
ourselves from a government that becomes
tyrannical that may use tanks or
whatever else in the modern era
purported ostensible democracies like
the United States they rarely become
authoritarian or tyrannical to borrow
the the word
the right-wing gun people like to use in
this cartoonish tanks on the street way
although Trump has talked about wanting
a parade with tanks they tend to become
more quietly tyrannical by attacking
press freedom by limiting the access of
media outlets that they don't like by
turning public opinion against
individual journalists and I don't see a
single one of them saying we've got to
defend freedom of the press with those
firearms yes a pre Free Press when the
president likes what the press is saying
and you will hear the defense that hold
on a second David he's not shutting down
the New York Times he's not shutting
down the Washington Post they are just
merely going to lose their White House
credentials we are experiencing such
scandal fatigue that I don't believe we
are understanding the gravity of what
Donald Trump is promising to do here in
his interview with sean hannity there
are times in american history where a
president specifically targeting the
press credentials of individual media
outlets that they don't like would be
considered impeachable but due to
scandal fatigue due to the dense
desensitization that we have experienced
as a result of the outrageous acts of
this administration this is an
authoritarian nightmare that is going
wholly unnoticed and it is being backed
implicitly and/or explicitly by the
Republican Senate which is another issue
that we've been talking about which I
won't divert into today and much like
would the ignored impeachment subpoenas
that I talked about earlier in today's
program there is ZERO indication there
was no indication that this is going to
have consequences unless and this is why
I keep talking about it and I actually
got some emails this week saying David
it doesn't matter that you're repeating
yourself like a broken record you need
to keep talking about this there may be
no consequences to any of this unless we
mode vote him out in November of 2020
it's barely 12 months away because
they're ignoring the subpoenas and
getting away with it they are going
after media outlets and getting away
with it they are terminating press
credentials and getting away with it and
there may be the only hope of voting
this out in November of 2020